what's going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and recently there have been some major
developments happening in the movie
industry and TV industry in general not
just affecting Marvel Studios but all of
the studios out there in fact as of
today all late night shows have been
canceled shows like The Late Show with
Stephen Colbert The Tonight Show
starring Jimmy Fallon these are now not
going to produce any new episodes but
are going to simply be showing reruns
and this is all because of a writer's
strike which started this morning the
writer's Guild of America both East and
West have made the decision to go on
strike and this will affect like I
mentioned all Studios really but of
course it will affect Marvel Studios as
well and if this doesn't get resolved
soon this will result in major delays
for Phase 5 and phase six including
movies like Avengers the King Dynasty
Avengers Secret Wars and other upcoming
movies that were supposed to come out
sooner rather than later but now it
looks looks like we might have to wait a
bit and this is really all happening
because of streaming services with major
Studios we're talking Netflix Disney
Warner Brothers Amazon Apple Sony all of
the really big ones we live in a very
different time now where streaming is
basically our main form of entertainment
with movies and TV shows it is dominated
cable and especially during the pandemic
where we couldn't really go to the
theater and watch movies streaming
services were where the movies were
released at so as of yesterday projects
coming from these major studios are now
on hold here's what the wga had to say
yesterday the board of directors of wga
West and the Council of wga East acting
upon Authority granted to them by their
memberships have voted unanimously to
call a strike effective 1201 am Tuesday
May 2nd which is today the decision was
made following six weeks of negotiating
with Netflix Amazon Apple Disney Warner
Brothers NBC Universal Paramount and
Sony under the umbrella of the amptp
though our negotiation committee began
this process intent on making a fair
deal the studios's responses have been
wholly insufficient given the
existential crisis writers are facing
therefore earlier today the wga
negotiating committee unanimously
rejected the amptp's final offer before
deadline and recommended to the wgaw
board and the wgae council the issuance
of a strike order and like I mentioned
that is the writer's Guild of America
West wgaw and the writer's Guild of
America East wgae and as of this morning
this has started the writers are no
longer going to work while they are
going to the studios but they are going
to pick it they are outside the studios
demanding better pay so basically the
writer's guilds try to get a better deal
for their riders in the studios did not
agree so now they're on strike and we're
not sure how long this is going to last
for it could be quick or it could be
months hopefully this gets resolved soon
but let's take a look at some projects
that could be very affected by the rider
strike at Marvel Studios now I think one
of the more devastating projects that
will be affected by this is what we've
been talking about a lot recently A
Fantastic Four now again if this is just
a very quick strike it shouldn't affect
it that much especially since Marvel
Studios right now is finalizing the
casting choices for the Fantastic Four
however we do know that if they even
have a script it's not close to being
done yet so the writing for the movie
will come to a stop and of course
there's only so much you can do in
development for a movie if you don't
have a script now again we do have some
time but the release date for The
Fantastic Four is now less than two
years away if this strike lasts for
several months it could delay the film
and unfortunately based off of what we
have heard from the news this strike
might not end soon The Writer's Guild of
America said that they could not come to
a Fair agreement however the alliance of
motion picture and television producers
which is the trade Association that
Bargains On behalf of the studios and
television networks and streaming
platforms said in a statement that it's
offered to the writer's Guild included a
generous increase in compensation for
writers so they have already offered to
give them what they call a generous
increase but the writer's Guild did not
accept it so it looks like the writers
are demanding much more since the
alliance of motion picture and
television producers said that they have
already offered a generous increase
right now what they are claiming they
want is a proposal that would require
companies to staff television shows with
a certain number of writers for a
specific period of time whether they are
needed or Not by the studio so you can
clearly see how some studios would have
a problem with that they wouldn't want
to pay for a writer if they are not
needed at that time now unfortunately
the movie that is closest to us that is
most likely going to get delayed is the
Thunderbolts which is currently set for
July 26th of next year 2024 basically
anything coming out this year should be
fine because the script should be done
for all of the projects whether that's a
Disney Plus show or a movie like the
Marvel should be fine however if they
wanted to go back and do any rewrites
that would be an issue it would get
rather complicated then and could lead
to some delays but the one that we truly
have to worry about is the Thunderbolts
and of course you have to remember that
if one project ahead of all the others
gets delayed then those other projects
behind it following it up they'll
coincidentally get the late as well as
collateral damage because Marvel Studios
is going to have to shift the entire
schedule if one shifts and if this
doesn't end soon what is really really
unfortunate is the movie coming up after
the Thunderbolts which was currently
still being written is Deadpool 3 which
is set to come out on November 8th of
2024. of course we're all waiting very
eagerly to see Hugh Jackman return as
the Wolverine and fight alongside and
probably fight with Ryan Reynolds
Deadpool now the only possible good news
about this is that Ryan Reynolds was
writing a lot of the movie himself and
I'm sure he himself could continue to
rate the film so this might not suffer a
huge delay but however like I mentioned
if the Thunderbolts get pushed back this
will most likely get pushed back as well
but of course the really big ones that
nobody wants to see get pushed back are
of course like I mentioned the Fantastic
Four but also our next Avengers films
the Kang Dynasty and Avengers Secret
Wars unfortunately these are at a pretty
big risk of being pushed back right now
because the movies that are closer to us
are closer to being finished however we
know that Marvel Studios has already
hired the writers for Secret Wars in
King Dynasty and they have already begun
to start working on these films well now
they have to stop but right now we're
hoping that they are far enough out
there with their release dates that
nothing will really happen to them and
they are scheduled to be a year apart so
even if the King Dynasty gets delayed a
little bit hopefully that wouldn't
really affect Avenger Secret Wars
however we have to keep in mind that
there are movies that are going to be
released in between them so it really
just kind of has a domino effect if one
project gets delayed enough the next one
gets delayed and the next one and so on
and so forth but some of them are always
out there like our Avengers film so
hopefully they are far enough out there
to where they really aren't that
affected and hopefully Marvel Studios
can just simply Shuffle their schedules
around just a little bit to make it to
where things aren't really super delayed
but hopefully they figure this out very
soon in the writer's Guild of America
can make a deal that they think is fair
for them and also fair for the studios
like I mentioned this could last a few
days or this could last several months
and if we hear anything else we'll
definitely be sure to do an update video
so be sure to subscribe and hit that
notification Bell so you don't miss out
on any of the latest news also don't
forget to subscribe and leave a comment
down below so you can enter our giveaway
for a chance to win an Xbox series X A
PS5 some Marvel Legends items or some DC
items winner gets to pick and we pick a
winner at the end of each month please
don't forget to like the video and you
can always follow us on Instagram and
Twitter and as always thank you all so
much for watching wolf
foreign